hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to 10 second if we got to go
whoops oh I skipped something hi
Mannion's it is I your glorious leader
robot Hitler for some reason I have a
couple of announcements to make let me
just list them off here hey guys one
second let me get my list down
where's light a number have you been
caught tweeting during our evil meetings
I don't like it very much
hashtag Hitler looks fat it's not funny
it's hurtful to poor Robo Hitler second
a long search is over I'm sure you have
noticed that we have been floating in
the void for a while now let me just
take a dramatic pause here reason being
that we need to begin our domination
averse with a bang another pause we must
destroy the ninja nothing is more
awesome than an index that maybe a
pirate by eliminating the first ever
ninja we will assert our authority of
Earth and make it ours
time periods be damned robot Hitler
invades when ninjas are in rain and we
land the ninja once afore I didn't read
that last line I forgot I was rambling
there because I kind of took a lot of
punch out of what this is gonna be all
about and this is all about speed now
I've been practicing this so I don't
suck and I don't want to suck because I
when I usually play these games and I
suck at them it doesn't bode well for me
like that that's gonna be the only time
that I fail I promise you that because I
am actually very capable at this now cuz
I made sure of it before I started
recording cuz I knew that I would be
making a fool of myself
oh I'm dead it doesn't matter I won
anyway I was so close to another star
hand I gotta do the better it really is
like well I'm not gonna do it oh okay I
should have just stopped while I was
ahead took in my star and then just gone
ahead there we go okay thank you so you
do have a second to prepare but you only
have ten seconds in every level to beat
every single boss on earth enemy on the
level such that you can continue forward
not suck ass and do better wait I didn't
do that right that's right
okay down hand wait for it for webapp
there we go I did it good I did a good
guys my hair is not cooperating with me
but that's not very important for this
yeah okay I get back up gotta get back
up it reminds me a lot of one finger
death punch which a lot of people have
been like saying that I need to play it
it's like I've already played one finger
death punch it was a great game when I
played it but kind of already played it
why do I need to play it again
Oh 0.9 seconds to the next how am I
gonna get that oh oh hey Robo Hitler how
are you doing so you only have ten
seconds to beat him as what whoa with a
big ol laser well that happened again
well alright yeah how do I get to him
quickly yeah there we go
whoa whoa okay whoa one star for that
that it's goddamn ridiculous oh holy
hell thirty six point oh four seconds
that's how long it took me to beat all
of those levels holy crap robot Hitler
we're being slaughtered down here we
need love what are you doing you're a
terrible artist I'm painting but you
don't have any arms oh my god
I'm Hitler you have you to give us some
weapons sure the ninjas cutting through
us like butter
we've lost 50 troops already really I
know I lost but my fight went pretty
well
no it didn't you shot a laser at me you
can fire lasers out of your mouth I was
born that way baby and that's fine but
we have no means of attack we just kind
of flowed there defenseless
you think that might be affecting morale
or these cutscenes sure take the speed
out of the game well I mean yeah but
that's not really my point very well
we'll share the trips up with a party
get me your finest party hat for a
second I thought that said penis party
hat and the weapons I'll sketch up
something for R & B good sir what
yo arms oh my god get out Wow no no joke
I only saw the first cutscene that took
every bit of speed out of the game but
here we go you not gonna suck oh that's
different
okay now wait okay hang on all right
hang on
buh-bam okay so now I got it alright
they still don't have any weapons right
so I'm pretty good here yeah I got this
baby I'm good I got this on lockdown
well maybe not coz I screwed up there
well bomb dead okay it's a it's a Trixie
ledge I don't think it's gonna be good
enough for me oh okay there's always a
more efficient way to go about things if
you look at it carefully because I think
anyway what's up terribly mistaken okay
got it
hope crap this is gonna take forever
there we go oh you can crush them I
didn't know you could crush them with
the rocks whoa what is that
don't Kelly oh my god oh whoops I I miss
that one okay did not know about that
guy oh I get it okay it's the only way
to get to this guy baby it makes me feel
so good what I do okay nevermind oh crap
oh I get it I need
who's gonna get it oh you pissing you
were supposed to go up now oh I can do
that way better you need enough stars to
be able to continue that's like a thing
you need [ __ ] shiitake okay so either
way you got a run through here so I
think that's like a limiting time factor
thing there we go
got it good this is getting a bit more
complicated but I'm a ninja I'm like
kind of totally really awesome but not
as awesome and maybe maybe a pirate
would be because pirates are pretty cool
I need four more stars good god what do
you want oh man this is where things
slow down a bit because my god I'm not
good okay so I need three more stars
damn this is very very very very finicky
so if I run up on those that's gonna
kill all of those guys then the only
things I really need to worry about it
the guys over here so let's do that I
got killed dead goddamn so how am I
supposed to be able to go over there
very quickly holy crap I didn't even
think I was going all that fast
okay tonight I just got to go back to
the beginning and do this right yep well
[ __ ] not that nut that's not right well
sure that's not right either I'm coming
for you yes yes is much better [ __ ]
pretty good not bad anyway this game is
actually really really fun whoa okay
then he's gotta jump over that laser
baby well I'm dead but that's okay
because I got him now time for an
excruciatingly slow cutscene hey mind if
I why do you get your moustache cut like
that how do you mean well it's such a
small patch of air it seems pointless
in my youth I got an embarrassing tattoo
on my upper lip of a mustache I was a
different person then reckless
while I'd rather not talk about it why
are you here then just getting closer
[ __ ] what oh oh oh that's beautiful
robot Hitler cut himself shaving somehow
okay so anyway the game gets a lot
harder from there and I don't have a lot
of time to play through the whole thing
in fact I probably look the best what I
was going through the first levels
because I played those already and they
can't it made me look good either way
that's ten second engine a lot of fun
but it's not a free game unfortunately
it's on Steam for ten bucks so take that
for what you will if you enjoyed check
it out if not that's ok too
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
because I'm gonna edit this and it's
gonna be an amalgamation of core that
people are gonna see me